[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my
in high school i always wanted to work
in the area of environment
protecting whales speeding after them
on boats and saving them from being
hunted when i was a child i wanted to be
everything from a fireman to an
astronaut
i even once remembered saying that i
would like to be a civil servant as a
kid my older brother didn't take it so
well so
when i was a child it was a time when
the films of indiana jones were very
famous and i wanted to be an
archaeologist and this is what i studied
when i was a kid i wanted to be a doctor
brain surgeon most precisely
[Music]
so as a linguistic assistant
my tasks are
formatting and revising the text that
get adopted all kinds of decisions
regulations and
international agreements
my job is to assist three working
parties in the field of
non-proliferation disarmament arms
exports and dual use exports i'm helping
to prepare the work of these working
parties together with the european
external action service and the rotating
presidency i ended up in brussels in the
council and i am working as an
administrative assistant in a policy
degree and assist my director general
with
part of his policy work i'm currently
working in two different jobs actually
so half of my time
is spent helping the general secretariat
of the council as an organization to
be able to address the challenges that
is coming its way through digitalization
the changing way that work develops
after the pandemic and in the context of
digitalization the other half of my work
is
the preparation
of the european council
and of briefings for the president of
the european council charlemagne
[Music]
there are several things that are very
pleasant at my job
it is service oriented i help people
with
things they are
needing for their work there is a lot of
variety so you can have a day
where you will deal with 10 15
completely different things from
administrative
to policy or practical matters i'm never
getting bored
because in this job you can really see
the results of your war becoming real
for example you draft a speaking point
for the president of the european
council or work in a political text that
becomes european legislation what i like
about this job or about these jobs is
that they combine the administrative
side where it can help the general
secretary of the council shape its
answer to the challenges of the future
of digitalization and the future way of
working
and on the political side that i can
help and contribute to shaping the
message that we send out as the european
union on behalf of the european council
working in brussels is being in touch
with all kind of cultures in a
multicultural environment besides in my
job what i like most is being in touch
with my mother tongue
[Music]
is
athens
[Music]
you